here let's uh let's let's let's do this
so first i'll show you this the more
serious news and then we'll cry a little
bit about how insane this whole story is
fox news says nba calls off playoff
games after milwaukee bucks boycott game
over shooting of jacob blake
the players forced the league's hand
after protesting the sunday shooting by
kenosha
police of jacob like a 29 year old black
man so that's the gist of it
but it gets it gets crazier milwaukee
brewers
join bucks in protest sit out game
versus reds after jacob blake shooting i
got a theory about this
have you seen any of these games they've
been doing
the basketball games recently because of
covid yeah you think the games have been
sucking so they're like
yeah like the ratings have been down 40
down
uh for uh so so actually i have right
here check this out out kick nba playoff
ratings
and esp are down forty percent ratings
my understanding across the board are
down
so imagine this right you're used to
playing major league sports you got all
these fans oh yeah
you know they're all yelling and you're
all excited and you you get the
three-pointer you swing your home run
everyone's cheering
now it's a bunch of cardboard cutouts
yeah and janitor's sweeping as you've
jumped on your opponent and you're
creeped out i mean i would be creeped
out
i couldn't imagine i i used to uh you
know skate in contests yeah long time
ago i couldn't imagine like
yeah figure skating for sure yeah uh
skateboarding
but there's people all over and it
really hypes you up when you're like if
i know i get this people like they cheer
for you they cheer you on that it gives
you that energy
i couldn't imagine like i skate by
myself sometimes
a lot of the time you're just skating
for yourself but when you're going out
for a contest and you're pushing your
limits
and there's no one there and it's just
like you just cough
off to the side the janitor he's
sweeping
and they expect you to perform your
greatest without support of you know the
crowds cheering for you yeah it's like
if you see i don't know if you've seen
wrestling without the audiences
it is a sad sight the guy's like oh i
can't hear you
it's just a cardboard cutout it's a
janitor
yeah dude i was gonna make a really
offensive check i won't do it
uh but uh so i wonder if the reason why
they're actually boycotting
is because they're all like dude we need
an out yeah like
the they're playing these games in these
rooms where there's like just like cur
like
i was watching i think it was wnba they
walked out of the national anthem
and they're not even in a court they're
not even in like an arena they're in
like a high school gym
well the fans of the wnba have been by
not showing up for ages
yeah they didn't have to worry about the
cardboard cutouts for that one they just
were like
you know no one's gonna be here anyway
yeah it's funny holy crap the attendance
is wild because they actually put
the biggest attendance the first the
first time the seats have been filled
i i remember when uh when the w when the
wnba
uh boycott thing happened they walk out
on the national anthem
yeah and i immediately pulled up the
clip from family guy like seth
macfarlane who made the joke not me
where he's like uh i don't know i don't
know if you've ever seen the joke but
it's really offensive
i mean by today's standards for sure not
so much back then but he's like
he's like and and you know so and so is
going to you know to make the shot she
scores two points and that's why she
commands
seven thousand dollars a year and
they're like but is it worth
but is the money worth being that
unattractive i don't know
that's for the fan to decide there's one
guy in this dance chair
that's a good that's five jokes in a row
i know that that was family guy
man yeah yeah the nba has been fighting
it by not dunking
for real seriously they can't dunk so so
anyway uh so this this is it running
layups and protests
so so they they they uh you know the
brewers are boycotting
nba's boycotting like i said i think
maybe it's because they're just
i would love for this to catch on and
people do with their normal jobs like
you know just a bunch of guys at
mcdonald's being like you know what the
fry cooks are staying home today
you're like for you know it's for
against racism and you're like which one
died you're like i don't know i'm one of
them
that's what they're doing they've been
calling for a general strike it's but
this is the funny thing
just a general strike of everyone in the
world that's what yeah yeah yeah so so
it's a very common thing they try to get
like a pajama day sort of
yeah yeah yeah like like an extended
siesta
nap time like people in the
mediterranean get it but uh a
general strike among the left is when
everyone just stops working
but they don't realize they actually
don't have the support
of like imagine just women did and
they're like women are just gonna stop
working and
everything just went back
everything improved efficiency went out
like as a strike we're
just gonna stay home and you're like no
problem no one come on hey if you don't
mind making dinner today
i'm not saying that women shouldn't work
i'm just saying if they care about
racism
they might want to consider that option
that's a great option
the funny thing about that is their
people aren't working man
like businesses are shut down the
permanent club if you do have a job this
probably isn't the time to
you know be making crazy i think i think
the way they see it is
now is the chance to finish off the
beast you know everybody's laid off
so there's only a few people working you
know mcdonald's and and you know the
grocery store and stuff
so get them to go on strike and there's
nothing left maybe that's maybe that's
the general
political idea to it dude these like all
that stuff is like everyone's not like a
20 year old activist like he's telling
some normal guys like 50 years old he's
got a family you're like
yo you're gonna you're gonna like let uh
not go to work anymore for the next week
and you're like why you're like oh we
got a whole thing going on at the
university
he's like what are you talking about
yeah yeah yeah my my gender studies
teacher said it'd be a good idea and
he's like
i might i gotta i gotta pay my kids yeah
i have tuition i don't know life
yeah but that's that that really is it
so so check this out so
so we know all this is going on but now
we got to get to the best part
yahoo sports players association in
active talks
with players about logistics of
potentially boycotting games so this
happened earlier this morning
i'm reading this article i started
laughing
there's no way this is real check this
out they say an assembly
organized by players who are emotionally
traumatized by the latest police
involved shooting of an african-american
that was captured on video
was held tuesday night at disney's
coronado springs resort sources said
and there were multiple conversations
about what the actions could uh
could be taken throughout the day so the
first thing happens is i'm talking to my
friends and i'm like do you hear about
these these nba players and they're like
i can't talk i'm too emotionally
dramatic yeah
they're crying i called them up and they
were like i can't process i was actually
emotionally traumatized because i
watched a wnba
right game ryan came in and when he
first came here uh i mentioned
what happened and he broke down i just
said hold on
so so no but but in all seriousness the
only thing that will help
if i can watch you do some sick
knowledge
and that's when i started crying because
i'm traumatized yeah no no so i i did i
sent it to my friend
and uh they didn't believe it like i
didn't believe it either
and i i sent a screenshot of where it's
at the players who are emotionally
traumatized they're like this is like
onion right yeah no it's not the onion
check this out it gets even better my
favorite part i have no idea
what they were thinking when they wrote
this
here this is okay i gotta i gotta give
everybody a warning this is quite
literally on yahoo sports's website
this is real athletes aren't immune to
being racially profiled
sources said as a tactic to avoid being
pulled over
a few players have purchased teslas
believing that police wouldn't suspect a
black man to be operating that vehicle
now the reason why the first the first
thing i saw there was
it sounds like like some rich dude it's
like oh i
i they're like you bought a tesla that's
like kind of expensive don't you think
shouldn't you buy like a normal car
well uh it's because the police
um wouldn't profile me in it
yeah yeah so like their accountant is
like i don't know how you're justifying
this fifty thousand dollar car
uh black black lives matter
yeah how can we how can we write this
off call it a security expense
also like lebron james like a tesla's
got to be a drop in the pan for these
people he's like
i needed a fancy car it's like tesla
they're like what like a 50 grand it's
like
you get a ferrari if you want lebron
james yeah he's like
because of racism i had to drop this
insane amount of money on a car i'm like
you know i had a fleet of teslas what's
kind of crazy about it though is
i think that straight up is racist the
fact that
this idea exists that a cop is gonna not
pull over a tesla because
like this is the world they live in and
it kind of freaks me out they really
think the cops are like
in their cars going like what's like
flying to minorities
and then like they see a car drive by
like virus go after them
it doesn't matter what your car is in
fact a tesla's more likely to get pulled
over yeah
i'd imagine i'd be more less likely to
get pulled over than like a honda civic
with like
souped-up rims yeah and just lowered
smoke coming out the black lights yeah
nine guys in the back seat
flashy cars get pulled over more you
want to get like a gray civic
and then you don't get pulled over yeah
get a honda accord if you want but it's
also it's also crazy this idea
that these guys think the cops can't
look through windows yeah
like you said in tesla and all of a
sudden the cops are like i can't see
what's uh oh
but i think it's not that they they they
view this world that way dude the fact
that lebron james said
that he's he's like listen i get the
sentiment but for lebron james
personally to be like yo i'm afraid for
my life personally it's like
you're not though like lebron james
comes out of his house and he's like
yeah that
good great basketball game now i have to
walk to my car and fear for my life
and you're like yeah i think you're
gonna be fine you're a seven foot tall
like the cops pull him over and they
wouldn't say like yeah you're a black
guy that's where you pulled over they go
yo are you lebron james yeah i know
seriously they know who you are
yeah especially like he's probably got a
driver yeah he's probably got a driver
he's probably he
i'm sure he drives himself he gets
pulled over in his very fancy car
and i'm sure it's fine one of the
craziest things about this like this
whole narrative they've had there was
there was a viral commercial
where it was like the talk this is what
freaks me out because i grew up on the
south side
of chicago and i talk to my progressive
friends and they really
believe that parents shouldn't tell
their kids how to act around police
and even firefighters or emts like it's
not their job to educate their kids
but what world do they live in no it's
serious like
i i see these stories it's no wonder you
get these super entitled
you know college students who that when
like have you seen that video in new
york
during the riots where this woman is
screaming at the cops in their face and
they keep saying move get back and she
goes oh
effing what and then the cop goes she's
coming and he grabs her and she goes no
no it's calling to her friends that's a
classic
yeah it's a classic move because she's
never been told like
here's how you appropriately deal in
like these circumstances i mean listen i
was like a troublemaker growing up and
i've had run-ins with the cops and i'm
not like
some pro cop guy right but also
like i've had times where a cop beat me
up i've you know been tons of nights in
the drunk tank and all that stuff
but i never really like it still sucked
and i you know i was like
cops are kind of losers but i didn't
come out of it being like
i was innocent completely and i'm not
saying everyone else isn't but like
most of the times that i did it i like
looked back and i was like yeah i was a
little out of hand that night
yeah yeah but you know i i grew up
and everybody i know in my neighborhood
was told like hey man when you get
pulled over you got to do you got to
turn you
turn you turn the engine off take the
keys out put them on the dash put your
wallet in the dash
put your you know turn the radio down
turn the dome light on put your hands on
the on the wheel
yeah and wait for the officer to walk up
and then when you ask your id it's right
there in front of you
and then you do that just to make sure
everybody feels safe and secure
it's like these progressives act like i
was told put on f the police
full volleyball blast and stare at him
without blinking
and hold your and hold your hand in your
shirt as he walks up and give him a look
no don't do that don't do it don't do
anything like that i've had some wild
caught the
but like you know it's this the problem
is it's with all this stuff as they
shove it down your face so much and then
the times when they when they're
actually like oh the cops are wrong
there it's hard to defend because you
just
it's like when they're like everyone's
racing everyone's racist then there
actually is one you're like i'm just
done
hearing about people being racist yeah
but i've had this is the one that always
makes me laugh there was when at my old
house in toronto
these cops busted into our house in the
middle of the night
this at like 3 a.m they knocked down the
door and came and they had guns there
was like five or six of them came in
with guns
busting the door they started flipping
our mattresses they go everyone cuffed
up put
and there was girls there too so they
put the girls they're all crying like
you know they're like you know 20 year
old girls like why are we what is who
are you people
you know so anyways they bring us out on
the thing make us sit there it's like
winter
and then eventually when this all said
and done they're like who's so and so on
we're like none of us
and then they were going is this not
five ab street and they're like
oh they were at the wrong house damn
this is for real and then
nothing happens they turn their house
upside down then they just go all right
well
good you better not have any guns they
just sort of move on the next house
you're like you know it's not like cops
are always
in the right but no i and i think i
think
i mean so so you're talking about canada
though right yeah i mean cops are
probably
worse here than canada yeah but that
story was in isn't it yeah so
i mean the six is the hood i mean you
wouldn't last a day there it's a real
tough place
all right no you grew up in chicago i
was uh i had a place
near um used to what used to be called
commission park now it's us cellular
field in chicago it's
where the white sox play and one day me
and my friends are playing we were
playing gta
and the cops just kick our door in and
they come up with their guns out
and they're screaming i can't it's been
so long but they were like where's jimmy
or something like that and the three of
us are just like who
and he's like where's jimmy it's like me
and two of my friends no one's name
no one's name is jimmy and then they
they walk to the house looking around
and we were like we moved in two months
ago and they were like oh
and they leave oh my god like that
should be pretty high on the checklist
before you break a door down
is make sure we got the right one well
they did it was the right address oh it
was the right
whoever whoever they were looking for
didn't live there anymore and so these
cops
no warrant nothing i guess they were
looking for some guy and they
chicago's got cop problems man they were
looking for
james out front and they were they knew
what they were doing they saw lebron
yeah imagine lebron james had like a
really good point because the cops are
legitimately like yo wouldn't it be
funny to pull lebron over
once a week and then he's like i'm
telling you these cops are after me
oh lebron james the cop started to get
you
he's like i swear and then like uh
there's a you know one of his his
manager is talking to somebody and he's
like i'm telling you there's cops
and then the man just like he's just you
know he's a little bit yeah he's not
they get the rest of everywhere
i mean i mean but
you know what's funny uh you're making a
joke but that's exactly what it sounds
like they're saying yeah it's not that
far off
yeah man so i wonder i wonder if this is
offensive enough that youtube's gonna be
like let's turn this one off you know
yeah yeah really this is youtube is is
nuts man the censorship is getting crazy
yeah they were they were hard on i told
you i did this stock market video
yeah but you know you know it's like you
never know what they're gonna get you
for you're always like oh this one's a
little crazy and then
nothing and then they get you for
something you're like what that's not
doing
i i i have videos where it's like i was
talking about joe biden
yeah joe biden gets accused by these
women of you know being a little
touchy-feely with them and then it's
like this big scandal
and i'm like joe biden did this he did
that and they're like all good yeah and
then i do a video about like a tv show
and they're like whoa
whoa whoa you can't talk about sex and
stuff like that what do you
and then it's the craziest thing to me i
i can i do a segment
and it's like they have this thing
called self-certification on youtube
where you choose
does this appear in your video i do that
too yeah and so i'll be like
it's serious topical analysis there's
nothing too crazy i don't show you know
graphic image or anything like that
and i have no idea no idea why
some videos are good some are bad and so
i'm constantly in talks with google and
i'm like
okay let me get this straight like this
video right here is good and there's
it's
it's a story where i'm talking about a
guy who took a bullet in the chest and
then dropped dead another guy got a bolt
to the head that's okay
and we're showing the guy with the gun
just not any graphic imagery yes okay
now this one
i talked about kamala harris running
with joe biden and you flagged that as
hate speech
that one's offensive that one's got to
go and there were
well yeah and in the video where you're
yelling the n-word for two hours
straight
but you know what but the crazy thing is
you actually can
say and use slurs on youtube so long
it's not directed at
yeah i guess so right but yeah they they
will throttle you they'll demonetize you
they just they don't love it
they won't ban you for doing it they're
like yo it's chill but like
yeah yeah yeah yeah we don't love it we
totally get it man you know it's cool
like do your thing but just you know
like we're not gonna tell the neighbors
about it
but yeah yeah so so uh you've got
you've got the woke racist video yeah
the two guys wearing shirts one guy's
welcome
they believe the exact same things yeah
and that one you didn't have any
problems with
no that didn't get censored everywhere
but i've had lots of stuff censored over
the years
but the i just thought it was funny that
i did the stock market like basically
the premise was like the stock market's
kind of overvalued
it was like not even anything crazy and
it got censored everywhere
that's so weird dude like uh like tick
tock took it down twice then it got like
demonetized and then it got um
like the the thing on twitter that says
you know it has
shocking content or wow so wait wait
explain what the video is like what's
the premise of this
of the sketch basically it's the economy
and the stock market
and the economy is like a bro partying
like whoa yeah this is never going to
end
and the economy is like we're very sick
because there's times twins
yeah you guys like maybe you're sick
like success is just a state of mind
he's looking at gary v's
maybe it's a siamese is that actually
offensive is it i didn't even say
siamese i said conjoined conjoined can
join yeah because i know that's a big
problem right yeah what is
why do we call it siamese it was because
there was like two famous people who
were siamese right i think so so i think
it was because it was like a circus act
like it was a chinese yeah kind of
terrible and so
the guy who started the circus tweeted
something that in
1840 they found out not so much he
chiseled something into a
into a tablet that is now considered
racist 150 i don't think
uh that siam doesn't exist it's not like
maybe it's that but it's hard like
you're fabulous right
yeah you you use the name of a country
that's no longer in existence therefore
no but i i think it's hilarious that you
made a video
it makes the conspiracy theory alarm
bells start going crazy yeah there's
definitely a lot of conspiracy theory
alarm bells that kind of go off on all
that stuff but the funny thing that
i think i was kind of saying this too
before but the funny thing about satire
is how these places decide what uh they
can put on and what they don't
is they transcribe correct me from wrong
because you probably know more than this
but they they did transcribe what's
happened in the video
on youtube and yeah right partly yeah
yeah into text and then they flag
certain phrases and
they can actually do they can actually
visualize
the text so like if you do a thumbnail
that says i don't know like a racial
slur it can
break the image down and detect the text
in the image right
and but also the words you say it's
there's actually i think it was
you can't just do the white power sign
willy-nilly anymore oh yeah they'll find
out and it'll translate the tax name
yeah i think it was keemstar he said uh
he said a word that i'm going to be very
careful and announce it very very
carefully
it starts with e then there's a hyphen
and the word
girl and the reason why i separated that
way because is because youtube
recognizes that word
as basically one of the n words
really e dash girl say it fast
and the translator said a word you can't
say
very and he got demonetized yeah so a
lot of people don't realize sometimes
the demonetization is because the
computer
doesn't differentiate between similar
sounding words
you know like if the the
i was thinking about this a while ago
because i was uh i can't remember i was
at i was at like a french restaurant or
something
and i was thinking about the
similarities bragging oh yes that's
right we had asked
no no it was literally like some new
york you know french-themed restaurant
yeah
and it's like pierre is poutine yes yeah
poutine
that's that's canada get out of here no
but i was thinking about how like
if you spoke very quickly you could you
you're priming yourself to someone else
like to someone doesn't speak english in
a very weird way like if you said
mister and my sister like right a person
doesn't speak english might not realize
mr is a dude and my sister they might
hear the same thing
yeah like my ex i was saying i think we
should break up and she heard i'm gonna
stay here for another two years yeah
exactly this is all in these linguistic
problems and you speak quick
but youtube mangles up what you say
because we talk fast and then all of a
sudden you're so maybe maybe what
happens is you're talking about the
stock market and like have you looked at
the tax it's all like a bunch of i said
is this
you know is israel and they were like
i'm a stock market in israel okay we
know what's going on here loud and clear
get him out of here
i've been willing to bet i'm talking
about the federal reserve and i
accidentally say yeah this is real
you're gonna get hush out look look look
i'm willing to be a lot of conspiracy
theorists are going like
oh yeah you talk about the fed you talk
about the stock market they shut you
down
so you know you know what's funny is uh
it has come up
people talk about censorship of
conservatives you know a lot on social
media
and and it's real but it's it's not so
much that uh it's conservatives it's
anti-establishment orthodoxy
so i would agree conservatives for the
most part are the ones especially trump
supporters so they see the most of it
but there are leftists like anti-war
anti-establishment
who do get censorship sometimes but for
the most part like
the establishment orthodoxy of the left
is typically okay
and that's another thing you were
bringing up earlier that was really
fascinating
that uh you mentioned youtube can't
detect satire
yeah so that's what i was gonna say that
because
if so that's one of the reasons why
people will do videos being like oh i'm
like a q guy right
and then bet you say all this stuff
you're like oh trump's doing this and
he's the pedophile rings and
hydroxychloride and whatever
whatever i don't know i'm sure people on
the internet are like that's not what
they think i don't know
but if you say like oh i'm gonna make
fun of like the far right or something
and you say all their talking points
then youtube goes like you're not
allowed to say that stuff take it down
but if i come on and i'm kind of like no
there's 75 genders and whatever right
they take that phrase and they're like
75 genders we see no problem with that
yeah
there you go yeah because you're making
fun of it but they can't tell this
archive you know so they're you're
making fun
so so i you you were telling me that
earlier and i was like that's right we
just have to say everything
sarcastically and wink right right
women are equal to men
[Laughter]
and again and and youtube's going to
translate that and the computer is going
to see it as a literal statement yeah
they're going to say this guy's bang on
dude
throw this and throw this mf in the
algorithm
truth bombs on this channel you have you
seen
uh what happened at this bookstore this
is hilarious do you know
titanium mcgrath yes so so they did a
display
of all of these woke books and one of
the books they put on the pedestal was
woke by titanium andrew doyle's you know
their project
and so you have like you know white
fragility and like you know
white whatever and then there's woke and
it just it they didn't it's this is
that's indistinguishable it's hard for
me to get out it's just
it's indistinguishable he constantly
does articles where they you know
basically prove his article
do you know about a few of those where
like i made jokes and stuff and then the
next day you're like yeah no that's
that's what they're doing for real
dude how many how many times has like
the babylon b or the onion come true now
dude it's it's like they're predicting
the future at this point i'm gonna need
them to stop writing some of these
articles
nonsense some of it's getting like
creepy
predictable but man
there was uh one thing that always made
me laugh just because and also bringing
it up because you you worked at vice
but because i i kind of hit them hard
and but i did an article there's this
girl that got fired from vice right and
she was like
really mad like they're getting rid of
i'm the only person speaking for trans
people but like
the answer is like no one's reading
these articles because right garbage
and it was all like you know why men are
cutting off their penises in solidarity
when they're not even sure is that what
she was really writing dead serious
so basically i i used half of the vice
articles and half ones i made
made up and no no one could tell the
difference like you know why animals are
actually trans and
there's all this kind of stuff right
yeah but when i was uh
i kind of go hard on them too because i
remember when i was
this when i was in canada i did they
kind of came to canada and they're like
oh we're gonna spend they made this big
venture deal and kind of said we're
gonna spend money and then didn't really
but i was in a meeting with the guy and
he said for me verbatim we were i was
talking about like the show about some
guys in bands and stuff like that and
he's like
we're trying to do stuff with things
like refugees like stuff that's hot
right now
whoa dude the guy advice looked me in
the eyes and said we want to do refugees
because they're hot right now
for like yeah for what like
entertainment content yeah like we want
or we want articles and shows about
refugees because that's what's up right
now and i've never forever got that
i've got similar stories man i worked
for uh one company
where i was i was uh talking in one of
the higher ups they were really confused
about what the direction of the company
because when the editor-in-chief was
asked by like their salespeople
what's the mission of our media outlet
he goes
gender and i'm not i'm not an
exaggeration i am not making a joke
like i'm a serious guy okay and they
were like huh and you know what
it's a whole thing for next year and
they were like
okay okay then he said what is it good
for
i i'm like could you imagine dude like
vice walking up to you and being like
we're really interested in like
refugees for entertainment like yeah
what
and you're like what about him it's like
you got any jokes yeah well i was saying
that i was like because it was a show
about bands and stuff and i'm like what
am i gonna do
the hit song refugees alive
dude dude it's wild yeah but there was
also this funny thing in entertainment
that
one comedy especially like um there's
this weird thing where
some people think that if you're you
know when some people have the idea that
you're certain groups you're not
supposed to make jokes about you know
what i mean yeah it's kind of like but
you go imagine you're in a group of
friends where it's like you can talk
about him but like don't talk about
you know don't make jokes about james or
whatever and james is like
yo dude that's and then i'm not really
in the group right if we can't talk you
know and i've always said
that when you do stand up you actually
look at people that make fun of everyone
everyone kind of leaves like a pressure
release and they feel better it's
obviously if there's like a guy in a
wheelchair and you rail on them non-stop
but if you just treat them like everyone
else people actually like that way
better but when you kind of set those
tones
it puts in a weird situation especially
this is why there's all these
conflicting agendas because they go
diversity is really good and we need
like diversity in sketches right
but a lot of sketch comedy you're making
fun of the thing right so they're like
you need women and trans people in
sketches also you can't make fun of them
and you go so what like my comedy
sketches just have to have like you know
indian trans people that are the heroes
and like that's not really and so
there's no joke well you should go what
am i like
i'm fine with putting so i always say
it's funny when they ever go like there
needs to be more diversity in common
you're like loud and clear
lots of black guys yeah you do black
comics kick
you know they're very funny right thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we
do the show live monday through friday
at 8pm if you want to catch the full
show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you